une production du studio sfr
bienvenue ou sans filtre et le podcast
on parle de nous inviter bhk d'un plant
avec la nouvelle année commence vous
avez sûrement un projet de podcasts
parce que tout le monde un projet de
patience mais vous pouvez penser que
c'était trop compliqué puis pour les
ports vous embarquer dans la technique
mais le studio sf on offre nos services
de location c'est bien que tout le
matériel avec l'espace ça vient avec la
technique des techniciens on va avoir
très bientôt éminemment plusieurs
espaces avec plusieurs ambiances
différentes vous fait calées sur le
studio sr point c'est au pouvoir avoir
plus d'informations et nous écrire
évidemment pour répondre à vos questions
ces zones
cette semaine on fait la fin d'année qui
dit fin d'année fait revue de l'année
fait retour sur cette année qu'on vient
de vivre et c'est ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui avec les best-of 2021 avec
php mois de tous les deux choisi des
entrevues en fait des départs 4,9 et qui
nous ont le plus marqué que le plus
apprécié différents styles de podcasts
en jeu 6 3 chacun cette dimension en
arabe à la fin puis on va les voir aussi
des extraits de bons moments de ces
podcasts alors si vous avez pu écouter
ou si vous avez tout écouter ils
voulaient revivre des moments forts
s'amener au säntis pas de casse alors
qu'était pour vos pieds 11 ans ont
commandé 11 nos impressions en tout cas
ma conscience en cette fin d'année alors
c'est toujours un plaisir de faire des
petits pas de caste je sentais
totalement
bh on va les remercier commentaires et
appréciations veston
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sous le beau c'est sur le long chemin
tout blanc de neige blanche
vieux monsieur s'avance avec sa canne
dans la main
et il va être entendu la version de
ginette reno de vivre le vin non c'est
incroyable je me donne c'est excitant
orchestrale un peu mais c'est vraiment
du genre serment bien on les coutures
comme là on n'est pas encore moins une
fille blonde est située la bombe et tué
dans dix d'entre eux n'en voudrait que
tessa et on est dans notre best of
2022 tire à sa fin ou est déjà terminée
tout dépend dans quel qu'en soit le
podcast semaine en semaine à
puis là on est en train comme à chaque
année de faire notre rétrospective de
l'année qui viennent passer année qui a
débuté avec un podcast ou est ce qu'on
annoncé le nouveau podcast productions
originales sexe oral
qui a flâné luxe qui ça fait un an que
c'est que ça râle existent ces projets
le bureau puis ce genre devenu un dit un
des plus gros au podcast au québec c'est
devenu un effet incroyable
la fille soldate dans une heure non
c'est vraiment un phénomène incroyable
s'est passé mais c'est vraiment un bon
les filles sont incroyables qu'est qu'on
a mis le podcast lancé l'idée comme seul
qui zonent pigeonnier puis on me coucher
avec salle est bon mais je vais pas que
les faits elle est aussi bonne que cela
rapidement puis pauvres est en fait job
incroyable
on peut retourner parce que l'on va
mettre des extraits dans le fond une
petite intervention depuis mois pile on
peut retourner nicole prince en unicode
états unis est aujourd'hui le biais
des cons on va aller voir un extrait où
est ce qu'on parle un peu du projet de
la naissance du projet dans le fond avec
les filles début 2000 22 début 2000 21
premières en fait première premier
podcast 2021 extraits c'est très un un
point qui semble revenir dans mettons
quand on parle de sexualité si le
laisser aller parce que j'ai
l'impression que c'est quelque chose qui
retient vraiment beaucoup de monde le
sait
maintenant juste de ma propre expérience
je pense je parle d'éjaculation féminine
mais ton au dessus de ma propre
expérience les fois où est-ce que ça
c'est le marché c'était kadhafi à se
laisser juste à l'islam il y avait un
petit revenu ça marchait pas de cépie
comme si quand même des bonnes
statistiques le t2 de fiction capable
d'éjaculer en fait je suppose c'est 100
% ou 6
je n'en entends du genre 80 pour sa main
tout moi j'ai tout et il pleuvait jacut
les cetc toutes les filles peuvent
véhiculer ses pas on n'est pas trop de
femmes fontaines ce syndrome fontaine
qu'on peut te d'éjaculer c'est quelque
chose qui est ce que tu veut le
développer ou poté pas obligé
c'est ce ça se peut qu'il y ait des
femmes sauvegarde avoir des orgasmes
saint jacut les il y en a d'autres qui
vont injecter 100 voire casser mais moi
je trouve ça plate s'est rendu le héros
de mon étude monribot harry mais ça
arrive moi c'est comme l' écart sépare
c'est sûr mais c'est à petit le regarde
plus fort de ma vie même salaire ouais
mon corps s'est à chaque fois non c'est
que moi c'est que j'ai réussi ce je
travaillais encore beaucoup avec mon but
c'est d'essayer d'avoir mon orgasme en
même temps d'éjaculer
tacle mon regard
de la face et la pratique le pauvre est
jugé sérieux les bras cette brosse à huy
découverte de jeunes max est ce pas ce
drame
produit par jacques ouverte plage tu vas
pas sauver jusqu'à quatre litres de
liquides corporels lui tu as tu peux
jouer longtemps sur un code promo là
dessus
et oui ana
ces malades c'est fascinant c'est à dire
que je suis coupable de jamais m'être
assez
informés par rapport à sexualité toutes
les diverses pratiques les tiges au jeu
commence le dans mes valises et quitter
maintenant mais c'est
sûr et certain il ne s'était pas ce
n'est pas une blague est une priorité
j'imagine je serais tout à fait durant
est rude mais je pense que c'est
peut-être plus un réflexe pour les faits
de gloire d'un devoir s'informer parce
que c'est peut-être plus dur pour nous
connecter à notre corps
quelqu'un qui est capable de venir
puissent instinctif puis c'est bon tout
est beau c'est sûr qu'ils étaient
peut-être moins le réflexe de voir cette
forme et le fait que c'est juste c'est
si legault si il sait pas qu'il y ait
beaucoup de couples c'est pour lui que
sa blonde adapté à la peau même des
plaisirs fac lui parce que c'est pas non
plus
c'est que ces points importants où j'ai
eu autant ses opus à l'aise dans ma vie
mais c'est une question que j'avais
aussi justement
je pense qu'il ya le plein de coups
parce que ça fait sa pub avec le tarn
est honteux peut-être de moins en moins
des relations sexuelles c'est comme ça
devient ce la norme ça devient plus dans
le non-dit houkes mata bout de genre
d'en parler depuis le mettons aussi en
d2 veut aborder ce sujet là de haïti
peut-être qu'on devrait si tu travailles
et ce ppi le tissu passa plus facilement
devenir une source de conflits mettant
ses pieds pitié
je pense que mettons une relation qu'une
personne soit ça peut être de plus en
plus en exprimant des affaires où
justement de plus en plus dans sa
réponse quand dans ce qu'on connaît on
veut pas trop explorer disputé mais
aussi après quatre ans thé avec
quelqu'un
tu amènes nouvelle affaire où tu d'y
agir mais c'est peut-être plus d'un même
réseau qui confesse plus tu le sais quoi
depuis les plus j'avais 3 ans qui est
insatisfaite ou la fatigue le plus
longtemps tu en parles pas le plus gros
l'éléphant dans la pièce de vie le plus
dur vient d'essayer de nouvelles
affaires je pense qu'ils commencent à
mal comment la main toi mettons quels
conseils donneriez à quelqu'un dans
cette situation au lieu d'un bain
balisant d'enfin donner à vos conseils
c'était bien avait dit c'est qu'on
conserver les fantasmes et houleux de
demander à la personne c'est quoi toi
qu'est-ce qu'est ce que tu aimerais qu
est ce que tu aimerais avant de dire et
moi j'aimerais ceux de demander à la
personne et après super c'est ce que
veux tu être mandatés j'ai l'impression
que ça arrive un petit mettons mettons
qu'on prend l'exemple d'un coup que ça
fait quatre ans qu'ils sont ensemble
puis des arcs et quelles sont les
démarches que je peux faire pour raviver
notre sexualité j'ai l'impression que ça
arrive un petit peu comme un cheveu sur
la soupe d'arriver à l'autre fargo mais
j'accorde ont géré le jeu
sexton mais mais mais mais même type de
demande et les fantasmes comme à lyon un
tchèque c'est que ses côtés fantasme de
chati le mieux placé comme pourquoi tu
veux mesure que ces gens je pense que
comment je la mènerai quand même d'un
professeur papa pour du cash mais c'est
normal j'ai jamais été très longtemps
que
je pense que jamais dre mettons là que
ce après 4,1 à tout jamais utilisé de la
série de champs d argent ben je pense
que je ferai quelque chose pour la
personne c'est à aller quelque chose de
nouveau mais pour cette personne fake
c'est pas comme si tu avais un besoin
qui manquent étaient ces gens parce que
tu veux ajouter quelque chose qui peut
plaire à l'autre fils je sais pas la
meilleure façon d'inclure les produits
rêveur c'est en lui faisant vivre à lui
une expérience parce que signifie dans
mon monde je ne veux pas que je sais
déshydrateur poggia set 6 jeux parfaits
à ce moment le on va pas on va pas y
aller avec toi on va y aller avec lui
avant comme si on lui fait découvrir à
lui que c'est des produits ça peut être
le fun ça va pas te remplacer toi c'est
cela par tout le temps ils n'ont pas que
je rate à ça ça va le remplacer lui au
incline à qui on va lui faire découvrir
à lui ont valu faire une expérience
celle il ya des scénarios tu sais quelle
que je propose tout le temps puis après
ce délai votre ip puis après soeur en
tranquillement on une autour on est de
retour pis leur retour c'était sexa la
7è sexy et drôle parce qu'à cette
époque-là on connaissait pas jouanny
genre puis lisant presque pau jean
restait qu'un peu maintenant son genre
inséparable de son nom à lestrem arrière
maintenant qu'il a acquis mon équipe
ouais mais genre c'est drôle que je
ne connaissais pas dans l'excès à ce
moment c'est maintenant que joannie
mettons une fixation sur les prostates
c'est comme un running gag c'est comme
tout le monde et ses méthodes mais
george aurait coûté le podcast à matin
en préparant ce qui comme l expliquait
le plaisir prostatique soirée que la
première fois qu'on entendait parler
hockey ouais ouais ouais
très cool que l'on va donner dans le
fond de nos de nos coeurs de l'année
de l'année 2021 je peux commencer ou du
plus grand c'est sûr parfait dans le
fond mois initialement on avait reçu
tissus et au podcast avec joanie puis
les angles on a voulu approfondir nos
discussions autour de la sexualité on a
déjà des relations puis les feuilles sur
cinq sera l'avait reçu au lit avec anne
marie que moi j'avais quitté le parquet
j'ai trouvé ça extraordinaire fait que
nous irons voir on voit invité à marie
pour nous parler de ça pour me parler de
relations de sexualité puis comme de
fait ça a été vraiment un très très
chouette podcast oui après la fois que
je te matic et j'ai entendu ces packs à
6 après en fac entend dénoncer les
scripts sexuelle à deux sens les femmes
encore une fois je répétais matin puis
anne marie est vraiment
c'est un fou de la faune écouter mais
aussi très documenté est arrivé que ses
stats qui reconnaissait parker puis
justement puis c'était justement la star
c'était comme 95% cdd mettons des hommes
ont un orgasme agression sexuelle virois
65% chez des femmes enfin que puel
rappelle rosstat qui montre et qui a
écrit m qui le plaisir sexuel lipow
lipow égale d'un sexe à l'autre comme il
ya un travail il travaille à faire
l'éducation mais surtout un travail à
deux comme de plaisir de l'autre le
pétard mais 100% au travail il
faut stopper tout à fait tout à fait
puisque pas de cas cela c'est aussi dans
notre top 3 des podcasts les plus
écoutées en audio fait clairement et
résonner chez nos auditeurs le suivant
ce qui se passe en audio c'est que les
gens l'écoutent ou les font écouter à
des amis mettons les podcasts qui sont
sur des sujets pertinents comme ça puis
je peux comprendre mettons une blonde
envoyé son chauffeur comme à chaque don
ce type en quatre minutes contre la
sexualité qui était visé
veut pas c'est encore tabou même sont
entamées le 21 22
et encore comme des plus discutés et
pitié mais donc d'avoir un espace
pasquet genre c'est discuter librement
mettons
de manière documentée d'amanar tire
vraiment sans tabou pendant deux heures
de temps pour quelqu'un qui se posent
des questions
orales aussi c'est aussi japon nous dans
son coin go transit qui soutenait que ça
existait comme c'est le fun d'antan du
monde parlait pour vrais dessous ça être
ici ou en son genre et les quartiers
pauvres loi dans cette affaire parce que
parce que c'est abouti fait que fac et
roy m'a reboosté
autant le podcast avec les filles pascal
mairie puis le fixera l'exister comme
crime et y apprennent à faire
j'avais
passé comme crime à qui je peux
apprendre encore apprendre regarder
qu'on a mangé de bord
je me croyais
parfait mais croyez moi
vraiment on va lectures extraites du
podcast avec et avec anne-marie d'enfant
puis
john sayles ça arrive dans la vie même
en scène de rupture qui se laisse ton ta
partenaire petit souci que si tu reviens
demain matin la personne veuille que le
jour cette personne ne serait plus
jamais accessible qu'à penser à d'autres
choses au
moins parce que le choix c'est plutôt un
choix de plus droit de veto sur ce qui
se passait enfin que je pense que c'est
aussi ça vient comme ça vient rajouter
un peu dit
autrement question de titre le bon choix
ce que j'entends rien à regretter est ce
que j'aurai tout dit j'aurais tout du
beau du cégom remporté questionnement le
qui le font vivre des émotions honda y
en a tellement perdu régler les humains
que c'est une émotion qui veut rendre
désagréable réduire le team puis moi je
vais toujours ensemble avec ni nick and
com et
qu'est-ce que tu regretterait puis fait
pas ce que tu penses que vous
regretterez c'est comme l'émotion ou les
la sensation la plus comme vous je
regrette été impuissant impuissante
quand il dut régressé je suis d'accord
mais des fois j'ai l'impression que
mes temps c'est vraiment voir le verre à
moitié vide mais j'apprécie inquiet si
je reste avec mon partenaire je vaux je
veux pas vivre une telle expérience que
je regretter mais si je puis patronage
de regretter de tête avec 39 autres des
fouilles c'est comme si ton sérieux lose
lose chaîne nautique est pas parce que
je les joueurs et le team fax et le
catalyst avec tes besoins des valeurs
rentrent en ligne de compte qui fait
comme faux je m'écoute c'est dans la vie
faut que tu alignes avec toi même le pot
avec les autres parce que les autres
pensent si je pense que si c'est là que
tu prends ton recul puis que tu fais
vraiment une introspection
c'est important faire signer très peu
importe que ce soit en relation dans ta
profession est dans ta vie et familial
peu importe c'est tellement important de
faire d introspection qui oui ça se peut
que tu as eu un sentiment de regret mais
le sentiment de soulagement d'être
peut-être encore plus grande si en tant
que maman décédée capable de gérer ses
émotions le mes supposés petits
mettons-le aujourd'hui à 30 ans tt1
chaque expérience que tu vives de
création site apprend c'est que tu
apprends sur toi tu apprends aussi
commander lit avec une autre personne
qui subit sera meilleur que j'étais mes
chaussons ou mieux que des fois on soual
du moyen soit comme attirés vers quelque
chose qui équipent à saintes qui
destructeur pour lui versus quelque
chose qui qui qui est tombé de penses tu
sais pas pourquoi
je ne sais pas je pose la question en
deux ans tout ne
je sais pas je posais la question
combien tu y mettons tout le monde tout
le monde autour de tous les couples
autour de nous qu'on voit piqué c'est
tout en boule il ya des gens qui restent
ensemble puis c'est des choix ouais
c'est des choix salariés aux choix que
tu fais pour toi même tu sais je pense
qu'on se compare beaucoup aussi pour les
autres puis les autres dont l'air de
pion dans l'air de tout le monde fait
sexe comme quatre fois par jour les
gouvernements
l'écologie
tout à fait quatre fois par année mais
tout le monde en fait quatre fois par
jour fait que t'être électrons quatre
fois par année
je pense qu'on est dans une société où
on se compare énormément et que nos
choix deviennent plus tellement nos
choix on est vraiment très influencé par
notre façon prendre les décisions et
cetera fakty je pense que c'est de faire
attention à tous c'était à marie où les
canaris petit extrait comme une entente
c'était vraiment un bois de castres moi
j'ai quelques coups de coeur 10 cette
année y a pas d'ordre en particulier le
premier j'avais ce mât liste c'était se
fit brochu a way ceux-ci bronchique et
une invitée aux
ordres d'un haut niveau
qui existait
inégalités
personnes des charismes de prestance de
d'aplomb de connaissances connaissance
pitié
n'importe qui qui le vend notre vie soit
ici ou à tout le monde partage pas
d'aller parler que maman qu'on avait
subi de là où je les veux être moi par
cette femme le sait si c'est comme ça
c'est incroyable je dis là la force
calais au petit pied en même temps
encore une fois j'ai écouté des petits
bouts dessus de l'espace lui ce matin un
ppi
était tellement
mort et le dos le fait qu'ils étaient
comme automatiquement à 6 les bacs de
même dans sa chemise parce qu'elles
avaient le dos des correctifs et ne
pouvait pas se mettre comme ça l'écart
est comme un petit dépliant qui elle
avait le double aux
étalages en place il manque de la régie
va vraiment détendue mais avec le cap ou
bep par jour se plier à 90° fallait
qu'elle soit
[Rires]
angoissante la chaîne
ponzi a été vraiment ils
céderont leur écoute est parce qu elle
nous parlait pas des types et hcdh 1 me
jean était vraiment le ti à lavey a pris
nos noms pilon rady était vraiment genre
foule comme une prestation
toute la première partie où est-ce
qu'ils ont expliqué son parcours qui
était qu'elle a fait le conservatoire de
théo impliquer l avalanche et se piquer
comme hank et comment qu'elle est dans
le coma qu'elle a découvert que
l'économie de l'énergie c'est que vous
intéressant qui est pas par hasard le
principe d'un universel à succès comme
senior au my god si l'anecdote et qui
est allé en gaspésie joueurs expliqué
aux pêcheurs qui pourrait qu'ils peuvent
pas passer pour un simple qui font comme
genre ça fait dix ans que ce nous ont
acculés et le palais 19 ans il faut que
comme cal explique ce jardin des gueux
que ça fait 40 ans que c'est que c'est
sur leur métier et et puis comment qui
commet qui est devenu georges commence
cette fable qui est une des femmes les
plus importantes au québec font
définitivement tu fous le cpie
ça prend le des nerfs d'acier faire ce
job le pdg d'hydro-québec le temps d en
décider si elle a vraiment une personne
le très cartésienne en bonne solution
c'est fait je suis pas sûr qu'à dois je
pense que ça croyez pas grand chose en
fait y'a pas grand chose qui doit la
stresser enfants non non médecin qu'un
facteur convaincre la ville de new york
tente électricité c'est comme faut que
tu arrives le
principal fief où tu arrives le tout et
potentats laisse intimider mais surtout
je reconnais qu'à l'export la dynamique
aux états unis comme ça joue dur
genre elle-même spurs posent
ce qu'a fait aussi finalement quel hydro
québec on bute contre le saint-siège
après cas survenus sur le podcast une
autre part ça peut être sympa cas cela
aussi c'est que ça lui ouvre la porte
comme c'est eric girard les mises des
finances domaine a écrit parce que et
son équipe nous a écrit en fait après
avoir vu ce podcast et c'est quand même
inquiet non
c'était une bonne entrevue ça permet de
voir la personne derrière le titre se
suivant c'est quelque chose qui on est
on peut pas voir en tant que haut dé
présenter le même intéressant plus exact
des gens qui gèrent dans le fond tu des
gestionnaires mais
aussi des personnes aussi avant d'être
des gestionnaires c'est des humains une
nécessité d'allier
dans les noms qui te dit j'aurais aimé
tombe le 3 ans je n'aurais pas pensé
qu'on recevrait une personne de podcasts
mettons ces fibres au juge le pdg
d'hydro-québec puis le ton est que
gérard minet des finances et que de la
pop ans je rêvais pas assez qu'on
comprendrait
ouais enfin qui est d'abord débat
d'orientation dire écoutez l'extrait
parce qu'elle nous parle de ceux de
chemin sur parcours le comment qui s'est
rendu le hall et ouais bon et on voit
que t'es ce extrait ex écoute une longue
histoire mais après ça j'avais aucune
idée ce que je voulais faire mais l'auto
comme 18 ans qu'est ce que je veux faire
puis d'ailleurs système scolaire et on
embarque sur un tapis roulant pour
exposer sa voix en secondaire 3
t'appellerai de prendre une bière tapas
doit de construire une tour droits
d'entrée des bas mais pas tous décident
ce que tu vas faire d'investissements
un choix ferrante
six ans nature ou science humaine en
font leur trou tiens kiev il ya bien des
affaires qui étaient aucune idée c'est
quoi fake rendu loges comme je savais
pas ce que je voulais faire je me suis
dit
on va essayer quelque chose de
l'arche du fait que j'ai pensé
sociopolitique
histoire économie aux économies car en
fait quand même j'ai fait économie
encore là le bac ça a été correct mais
qui dénote j'ai laissé ses cages j'avais
si je me dis jeu correct je vais
finalement baby
ce n'est pas la grande passion ne sais
pas j'ai trouvé ma vocation non non non
non non père fait plus j'avais ans et
moi je me disais que j'allais et
économistes dans la vie mais on avait
des bons profs chp ou choquer diriger la
caisse pierre fortin s'est pas
économiste qui est qui qui est assez
connue au québec et ailleurs ça des bons
profs mais je je vibrais pop hymne à la
dernière année du bac
et on commence on n'a aucun droit dans
la dernière année à un cours optionnels
le titre fort c'est un petit gars du
coup face à une chose le fait que j'ai
choisi konami de l'énergie puis le prof
qui nous enseignait
c'est un syrien déjà à québec c'était
très dur antoine antoine ayoub puis huit
arrivées en avant de la classe pour
n'était pas beaucoup parce que
visiblement l'économie d'énergie ça
faisait patrie pedram ans il s'est assis
il y allume angie tente d'installer ont
fumé trop cendrier jeudi
puis le 6 mai nous parler de l'opep ont
maintenant atteint 2 n'échappe
pétroliers c'est qu'ils opèrent les
grandes compagnies pétrolières exxon et
bp l'échelle pourquoi il y avait été
créé plein les pays les
lee roy après s'être amené son amérique
plus il parlait de la consommation de
pétrole après ça il parlait du budget
des familles et que je tombe en amour je
me disais
ça c'est vraiment vraiment l'fun fait
que c'est ce qu'on fait on ne fait
l'énergie la presse à la dernière année
du bac
le prof me dit ottawa donne des débours
ch parce qu'on était un groupe de
ressources naturellement tabac dans des
bourses avec la bourse était pour rallye
en nouvelle écosse
pour expliquer aux pêcheurs les quotas
de pêche
on va les vivants nouvelle-écosse pour
s'imaginer dans une cabane mort d'amar
ça va être le fun on va les passer l'été
la
fin qu'on pas avec les chiens
mais qu'on en arrive là bas puis je
rencontre un fonctionnaire
le vendredi qu'ils m'expliquent ce qu'il
faut que j'aille expliquer aux pêcheurs
qui me donne une carte
avec ses l'est du canada puis des bancs
de poissons là dessus mais m'explique
que l'offre les bancs de poissons
diminuent il ya moins de ressources et
donc il va falloir que les cotes un
choix réduit plus fort explique saw
pêcheurs
dépend bien sûr que le ils vivent de st
mais ces deux là c'est la job de
l'agréable
bourse comme lille texas était bien
content que c'est au caillou bat après
oui puis je pense que j'étais naïve
alors
ça se passe au sous-sol de l'église le
dimanche soir la première séance que le
dimanche quand j'arrive avec ma carte
mais ce soit en espèces du train
d'installer de la musique la guitare là
aussi je me suis sûr du train de la
musique des guitares puis me souviendrai
toute ma vie mais que j'explique ça dans
mon anglais approximatif mais était
correct panne il puis la stricte des
monsieur bara qui n'ont ils sont tout
une fille du québec qui m'explique mon
péché moins de poissons en partant de
cela
alors là il ya un monsieur qui se lève à
pêcheurs qui se lève et en arrière puis
ils marchent tranquillement pierre
service 48 de thé on devrait dire car
l'hymne à québec handikaraté qui arrive
avec plein prime mon stylo feuilles
j'avais un gros feutre pour dessiner
c'est un marqueur de points avec les
envoie au large plein effet des
pointillés fin de ligne pointillée il me
demande en anglais et d est-ce que vous
savez c'est quoi jeune fille ce
nom et ça c'est la ligne des eaux
internationales
ok avec l'oeil des scènes deux bateaux
un petit bateau pas gobbato la petit
bateau il ya un drapeau canadien dessus
et le gros bateau il met un drapeau
japonais soit cela dessinée
fait qu'il dit c'est ça l'enjeu
mademoiselle l'enjeu c'est que les
poissons dans trois quines coeur de
traverser la ligne sexy c'est pour moi
qu'ils prennent ces gros japonais qui va
s'en aller avec les gens continuent à
pêcher le poisson
je trouvais qu'il y avait un bon point
j'appelle
monsieur
avait pas de cellulaire pour y avait pas
d'appel à tous expliqué mois soit il dit
celio raison mais il faut qu'on faut
qu'on diminue même
classé comme rap et parce que je te
capable d'expliquer des folies de même
puis john qui devait enseigner le
français à dalhousie en tout cas les
ouais en fait qu'on sait ramener mais
l'on n'avait plus chaud on avait brûlé
les sous qu'on avait pour prendre le
traversier pour y aller mais aller plus
vite qu'on avait le chien mais les
cantons est reparti et disons qu'on
avait juste assez pour mettre de
l'essence dans le tout
puis il fait qu'on sera menée avec avec
le shin bet arrive il y était fin juin
poggia pas d'avoir un chez pas d'argent
je suis juif
décision
on a une gentille la soeur de john est
formidable et nous a accueillis dans son
salon avec le chien est clair qu'il
fallait pas encore rester longtemps de
toute façon on ne pouvait pas faire ça
alors là je me suis dit tiens j'avais vu
administrer laval y avait quand même des
tableaux des jobs à faire mais lotscher
à fin juin il reste comme trois feuilles
le fait que là il y avait un boulot de
guides touristiques seul oui je dis à ta
québec connaissait ça oui j'aime
beaucoup de musiques
slaves ont été joués guide touristique
saint-louis jallet puis télé
on est à saint romuald salle m'appelle
sa ville vives aronian je prends je
prends le temps puis l'a jeté un peu à
l'avancé en fait je te pas mal à
l'avance je regarde à gauche piste et
chris s'occupe ce qu'il s'occupe j'avais
déjà des universités c'est antoine qui
m'avait parlé de sa soeur c'était une
petite société d'état qui s'appelait la
société québécoise d'initiatives
pétrolières à l'époque le gouvernement
voulait savoir ce qui est bien avec du
pétrole plus j'ai remis ça en place pour
voir si on a même vu quoi c'était
dernier soit dix disent que ça avait
commencé puis en fait de l'exploration
année oui alors je tiens j'ai du temps
je vais aller le mali voire des goûts
puis je suis arrivé là puis je vais
aller dans un bureau oui je crée mes
personnes voire voir juste pour voir
puis je suis arrivé la pia veine il y
avait une dame qui était l'autre
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour vous je
dois savoir la personne qui engage le
monde
vous avez vous rendez vous sinon j'ai
pas de rendez-vous puits sur le champ
legault qui s'occupe des ressources
humaines sort du bureau en question qui
passe devant la réception fait samedi à
pierre justement il ya une jeune femme
il y avait un peu de temps j'ai fait une
longue histoire courte il devait
recevoir cette semaine la france est en
stage en france économistes puis avait
décidé de faire son service militaire je
vous rappelle que c'était il ya quarante
ans j'accueille là il n'y avait plus le
stagiaire a fait boum je suis rentré là
puis c'est comme ça que j'ai fait ma
carrière dans l'énergie
parce que des pêcheurs ont décidé que ça
avait pas de bon sens que je disais
bîmes ascain france a décidé de faire
son service militaire hier ce sont mes
revenus pocas avec sophie brochu
incroyable ouais moi un autre dame
écouteurs évidemment ce avec paisible
sans drik donner ton ami qu'à ce moment
alain ont
commencé mais on commence à peine
relations d'amitié comme elle est
maintenant d'aller évoluer le changer
puis à la céda profonde il mais
ce qu'on a fait à fond dans ce podcast
le sait ce qu'on fait quand on fait des
soirées exigence du genre on s'assoit
pillon jose puis on va on creuse dans
quelques uns puis cette personne là si
tu ne parlais dans tout
comme en mettant des derniers mois
j'étais plus fort dans ma tête à un
endroit qui est mieux il ya beaucoup de
ça quand même les deux comme de soirée
on peut rentrer dedans ainsi de
comprendre pourquoi met-on
pourquoi j'ai agi de telle façon
pourquoi je réagis telle façon d'aider
ce pays au final que l'histoire était
quand même qu'ils en font c'est vrai
aussi que c'est un patin de marbre c'est
vrai qu'il faut que je déconstruis
s'appuie ont raison tipi dans le podcast
on a fait un peu sentir en fait le tour
en u11 genre des cyniques pic de ckoi
une discussion avec deux autres sont
vraiment bons pour justement rentrée de
dans le vidal il ya pas de ce monde mais
pas de moteur quelques soins c'est ouais
j'ai j'ai aussi écouté un beau petit
comme
on s'est ouvert ce podcast le monde le
dit pour le fait vraiment comme un beau
tour de temps peut-il l'extrait être de
mettre électrique tu veux mais tu es moi
je repense au moment où est-ce que
cédric
s'est ouvert sur comme ça des parts dans
sa désintox et comme toute histoire
distincte c'est rare qu'on entend
quelqu'un a parlé aussi vertement
typiques comme comme exterran du lot
commun qui ça ressemble à quoi sont son
ressembler à quoi sa vie avant lundi
dans midi c'est si ces bières
antidépresseurs vivant si ceux ci
c'était la liste ça finit plus et comme
par jour c'est comme à qu'il était mal
en point et puis et
puis juste pile après qu'un qui parle de
com
comment
l'important c'est surtout rives de
scarlett après cela c'est comme si le
maintenant que fut ce t il expliqué
c'est comme
le temps qui aura comme découvrir c'est
comme se connecter sur c'est quoi qui
aime c'est quoi qui aimait qu'un kit
eagle qui aimait faire
essayer de retrouver cessé de différer
leurs fins autres que la consommation
c'est avant tout la place maintenant à
repenser la taxe est vraiment beau terme
en touche en fait que
c'est vraiment puis pays est bonne aussi
pour pas laisser passer de la bullshit
neutrons la casse en quelqu'un dit
quelque chose qui est pas vraiment ce
qu'est la personne pense avoir comme le
coller dessus depuis
ensemble cette dynamique là est vraiment
décuplée et comme non lorsque tu viens
de dire le cpo sauf a dit lavrov
la vraie affaire finit par jaillir du fx
affecte cash pop était tu laisses tomber
un peu les mots comme on l'a fait
pendant le podcast dans le tournoi c'est
vraiment bien raisonné aussi ce podcast
le et beaucoup vont qui m'ont écrit par
la suite qu'ils ont écrit à pezi
conquerra cendres et que genre ça ça les
a aidés le cas smith découvrir on va
aller écouter un extrait nous quelque
chose qui le font extraits
j'étais un bon consommateur dans wimm où
j'ai consommé beaucoup ma personne ma
dépression le gibus a toujours été
ancrée un peu dans mois de d'évadés mes
feelings le style je vois partir seuls
chiffres mais des vagues d'ennemis
feeling constamment puis j'ai commencé
jeune encore sonnerie pyj je sais pas je
m'en allais ou ecstasy contenu des
radios aujourd'hui oui c'est ça c'est ça
qui est
négligée comment je pouvais filet puis
le pourquoi du comment puis je t'ai
toujours ce test est pas de l'alcool
c'est un joueur s'était pas jointe et
j'ai perdu conscience non je n'ai pas de
problème non jusqu'à temps que l'année
passée écoute est-ce que ça a été
accentuée par des sorties de
la tension mais puis à l'humain tout
mais je pensais que j'avais un problème
encore à ce moment là puis l'année
passée où
j'ai passé le plus beau jour de toute ma
vie que j'ai vécu
jetez
vous sortez avec avec des déchets on est
à l'appart puis une soirée étant venus
en intervenant maison piper zippy deux
jours sont arrivés à maisons prises et
sensible et à québec
puis
ils m'ont fait un hunter ancient
freemont et m'ont dit comme le cendrier
que ça ne savons pas le ca marche plus
le piment ti avait tout prix les
démarches pour la désintox peas aider
les informations puis je voulais rien
savoir timéo ça a été le le monde this
entry ning point de ma ville
si c'est là que se rendent aujourd'hui
c'est que j'ai traversé ce ne peut pas
être nulle part d'autre ailleurs que le
dans ma tête je suis pour ce
qu'aujourd'hui je te rup je suis bien
plus confortable que l'oeuvre deux ans
il ne fait pas croire batteries parce
qu'en d'aujourd'hui je suis bien que moi
même j'ai pas besoin de consommer le
tiche prennent bien je la dégustent je
laime je n'ai pas besoin d'en apprendre
plus
je peux pas croire en le sélectionnant
dit dans ma vie c'est le jarret plein
parle plus long terme
piet
j'ai accepté et j'avais dit sur gold que
j'allais avant d'être gaulle toute ma
vie que j'allais être pas bien pour
certains de vos atouts du tri je veux
dire je peux me lever le matin puis je
fais comme la crise damart depuis j'ai
la même vie qu'hier je ne sais pas
pourquoi puis avant c'était ben foster
maingeois il faut que je prenne une
bière fouet c'était fou le staff incité
je travaillais pas liva je faisais mes
shows de télé et puis je passerai pas
parler 3 6 mois presque j'avais un
cocktail inscrivent les jours le cssc
bien par jour 2 monsters je mangeais pas
je prenais du vivant antidépresseurs et
fumé trop g de potes quand je fume un
paquet au pech jeter est plus facile
j'avais dit bouger
non salées faut du tout
aujourd'hui c'est le chu rendu donc j'ai
traversé des temps pas être là mais je
puis j'ai retrouvé mes priorités de
retrouver les légendes j'aime autour de
moi fijm c'est fou non on est de retour
c'était l'extrait de 4,4 avec sandrine
et pezi qui était vraiment un beau
podcasts et les podcasts c'est le patron
qui était comme une autre dans le
ruisseau saint denis un qui sait le
moineau pas de casque va marquer
différents types de patients n'est pas
de casser les vôtres ça va vraiment plus
humain comme ceux des podcasts
scientifique on a ratissé large dans la
dernière année en podcast sur
l'actualité une autre présente sur
l'entrepreneuriat et nous rendent pour
tous les goûts ne puis
un de ses thèmes de paca c'est justement
sur l'actualité avec des journalistes ou
ou des experts sur des situations béton
soit géopolitique ou bref il est moins
risqué que j'entends ce moment c'est
celui sur le conflit israelo pour signer
avec sabrina mais qui était vraiment
c'est un des premiers qu'on a fait
danser comme genre dont noter on a fait
un nom sur l'afghanistan il est tout
aussi intéressant mais
avec avec avec sabrina c'était vraiment
c'est des conflits tu as moins complexe
pis
qui dit depuis tellement longtemps tiré
juste à la consigne est on n'était pas
excessivement longs oat avertissements
complexe qui souvent justement quand je
suis l'actualité ben c'est chouette
l'actualité de ce conflit le webphone ou
est ce qu'on a mais rendu maintenant
sans nécessairement tout le bagage
progresser pour comprendre mais c'est
dans un contexte qui fait que ça qui
comprend le conflit puis ça fait du sens
pis on je pense que c'est pâques ashton
vraiment russe entre que mouche sur noir
sorti des lieux en ayant une meilleure
compréhension vraiment de ce que ce
conflit n'est pas capable d'en parler
après où en parler avait en connaissance
de cause la place de juste avoir des
petites bribes de peut-être que la bande
de gaza c'est le pisco exactement parce
que c'était la banque puisse écouter
toutes ces appareils qui sont comme un
juste un peu flou mais quand même ok
maintenant je le sais je suis au courant
maintenant si c'est encore une fois
c'est de la géopolitique est complexe
mais il ya plusieurs
temps je repense à l'extrême à ce que
les expliquait-il dans le fond jérusalem
super sain pour finalement toutes les
plus grandes religions monothéistes le
christianisme le judaïsme que qu'est
l'islam qui te montre disputé presque
tout le monte vue revenez à ce
territoire le piqué
puis bref s'il ya un moment pas de cas
je me souviens que c'était comme on
parlait beaucoup de les derniers
derniers événements qui se passent et
puis là on a quand même fait un jardin
juste pour qu'on parte tout a vraiment
commencé au début ont pu repartir au
débuté avant les parties de thèmes
guerre mondiale c'est comme évidemment
le lit juifs vivent les pires atrocités
après son fait à qui on on vous vous
donnez un territoire et les papous puces
ivy en tant que peuple sa cause des
conflits et des guerres qui s'ensuivit
arrive ça sociaux les juifs les
palestiniens sont
sont occupés totalement ou sauce aux
sons sont confinés à certains
territoires en la piquant à fait car on
arrive aujourd'hui le jeu l'est vraiment
vulgariser mais vous allez pouvoir
écouter l'extrait août et pourrait avoir
la meilleure le meilleur portrait mais
bref
c'est d'époque à ce domaine que c'est
pas nécessairement ce que le plus grand
nombre d' écoute moi ça fait quand même
plus parler que dow est celui là il y
aura les faits parlent énormément
seulement une sur cette année il me sûr
le fait le plus parler moi même aussi en
aussi peu de monde mais ce monsieur
vincent vallières qui était venu y avait
10 ans j'écoutais solide comment
comprendre c'est cool qui étayaient vous
expliquer vraiment le contexte
l'histoire de sa sphère leurs noms n'ont
fait que
téléphonie et des podcasts que
chi x qui sont nécessaires du moins pour
nous pour comprendre quelque chose
puis je venais pas les seuls à vouloir
comprendre le fait que chaque oeil et
merci ça nous a fait voir l'extrait s go
c'est comment vivent à jérusalem comme
le cycle d'études est ici au dessus
j'imagine que ça doit être à la fois
vraiment
beau
mais à la fois tendu et on sait que
c'est comment est ce qu'il ya une
tension constante ce qui est ici car je
m'arrête arrivée à jérusalem où j'ai
vraiment pas aimé ça en ça a été long
avant que j'aime c'est comme si
parfois les premiers voyages qu'on fait
dans nos vies le tir on tombe en amour
avec le pays puis tout est
extraordinaire j'en avais vu d'autres
puis je me suis arrivée l'homme je me
suis dit c'est pas comme j'imagine est
jeté et j'étais un peu déçu puis après
j'ai comme appris à aimer le jérusalem a
aimé travailler en israël aimer
travailler dans un territoire
palestinien puis après le lunch plus
capable de décrocher je suis vraiment
attaché à cette région du monde
jérusalem
ça ressemble commenté jérusalem-ouest ça
ressemble un peu chez nous
bon évidemment que l'architecturé pas la
même mais si tu veux manger des sushis
pas de problème c'est pas les gens je
sais pas ce que les gens s'imaginent
parfois il ya des gens qui me disent ah
ouais
et on s'imagine colline avec quelques
ânes une église tiquement comme dans
tant de décisions
c'est moderne c'est moins moderne que
tel aviv par contre c'est pas le même
style du tout que tel aviv sous une
bulle et des gratte-ciel tous à
jérusalem du repose sur une architecture
spécial dans l'ouest des pierres un peu
beige un beige rosé le typique des
pierres de jérusalem c6 très très beau
il ya des quartiers qui sont un petit
peu moins beau parce qu'ils sont un peu
moins favorisés les quartiers
ultra-orthodoxes entre autres dans l'est
c'est complètement différent lot un
style plus palestiniens la rue
principale de jérusalem et à salaheddine
et des commerces c'est pas le même style
du tout mais aussi la ville reçoit pas
la jérusalem s reçoit pas le même
financement de la ville donc c'est
sous-financé quand même d'en séparer ces
témoins occidentalisée maintenant oui
tout à fait c'est beaucoup plus moyen
oriental je dirais même si les
palestiniens sont prêts très ouvert et
plein de femmes qui portent pas le voile
nécessairement des palestiniens
chrétiens
donc c'est assez facile de vivre
honnêtement c'est assez facile la
tension on la sent pas au tout le temps
vraiment pas même yeux pleins de
touristes dans la vieille ville de
jérusalem le même trop parfois je
rentrais je revenais de travail et puis
c'est quand on vient dans la vieille
ville mais là c'est creux donc là je
devais marcher sur à wall street le cac
comme la rue principale du quartier
musulman puis le racheter comme s'il
vous plaît excuse mais je devais essayer
de passer mais des groupes de touristes
mais c'était fatigant même temps c'est
que ça fait vivre les commerçants de la
ville donc je t'écris moi pour mon plein
de chimie palestiniennes israéliennes
donc ce but où il communique le
librement ouais y'a pas de check point
entre les deux ailes à vis à vis les
situer dans jérusalem est par contre
puis quand je vous dis que tout un monde
qui l'est c'est parce que c'est vraiment
différent tu le sens quand tu passes
dans l'ouest mais c'est super près là
c'est à dire que moi en étant dans la
vieille ville je sortais par la porte de
jaffa j'arrivais dans l'ouest
directement je peux aller prendre une
bière on allait prendre des bières avec
des amis ou à taklit là j'allais manger
des sushis aussi dans ce qu'on appelle
du rumen colonies après le même soir je
pouvais aller dans l'est aller sur une
terrasse avec une vue sur la vieille
ville
je sais pas moi manger de n'importe quoi
c'est
tout à fait donc c'est sinon c'est assez
facile d'y vivre on sent que les
tensions sauf que
quand tu vis là assez longtemps je sais
très bien qu'il suffit d'une étincelle
pour que le visage de la ville change
complètement c'est pas long là c'est
vraiment comme ça c'est un claquement de
doigts puis un moment donné le tout à
coup ça change le sait plus la petite
ville touristique l'ophone l'oasis de
coexistence plus du tout le je pense
qu'il faut vivre le puits bien connaître
le contexte pour reconnaître les acquis
sociaux ouais quand ça arrive on est
autour
un autre pas de casque marqué l'année
puis c'est quand même plutôt récent même
si le
on a fait d'autres pas de casse depuis
met le paquet avec patrick lagacé qui
est une légende absolue malgré tout je
voudrais pas si vieux que cela tu sais
pour avoir fait tout ce qui a fait le
break un cv à l'infini mais comme il ya
50 ans puis piste est en réel honneur de
la recevoir des fois il ya de monde
avant même ces comme d'aider
les écoles et c'est quoi le mot que
cherche le dr liste des idoles mais des
références dans le milieu et et puis le
monde du podcast s'apparente quand même
télécommunications le tir la
ddc le domaine de la communication pour
lui c'est une légende de ce domaine le
tuner radio télés radios au téléjournal
têtu c'est comme les communications les
médias pont neuf la pelade d'enfant puis
lui c'est vraiment une référence ces
puits un établissement ce jeudi en fait
c'est vraiment un honneur alors se voir
puis tout le temps phone c'est le long
ce
métis tout le talent phone afin du
podcasting je dirais les gueuses genre
c'était vraiment vous êtes vraiment bon
aperçu venant de lui maintenant c'est
comme crime c'est flatteur le partage il
découvre la vie au sans fil comme c'est
touchant quand même pu lui y étiez c'est
ça y est vraiment vraiment intéressant
puis tu vois que
il peut vraiment de place pour la
bronchite d'un dans sa ville qui comme
il veut dire exactement ce qu'ils
pensent puis il va avoir des fois de la
martyre et sociaux mais en même temps il
va tout le temps et le fidèle à son
opinion puis il va pas courir après le
clic beit de façon arthrite juste si
comme certains de ses collègues peuvent
faire il va juste rester oui va jouer
avec les codes si oui ça prend un titre
accrocheur des affaires de même quand il
fait des chroniques mais va jamais
essayé d'aller dans le mauvais goût dans
le déplacer puis je trouve ça vraiment
honorable d'avoir fait une carrière
comme cela ne va pas dans la
malhonnêteté intellectuelle notons le
cpie des saules à
3 h troc émettant martineau le tice qui
nous expliquaient qu'ils qui lui
reprochaient ce temps pressé de prendre
une chose hors contexte que quelqu'un
d'y créer une histoire qui rit et s'est
créé une controverse autour de quelque
chose qui est complètement fabriqués
localement mais la cause qu'ils étaient
dix à la base plutôt pitié
l'importance d'y revenir souvent sur
l'importance de la rigueur puisque
l'importance pour lui de redire checker
ces faits darty qui ces sources le plus
possible pour pour faire d'erreur puis
même si
c'est même si c'est de l'opinion la
rigueur
de fonder une opinion pour avoir une
opinion informés comment se baser sur
des faits commis sur quelque chose de
solide puis justement si je fais de
l'opinion mais deux basés sur des demi
vérités ou des demies fait ou des choses
présent contexte ben ça sert à personne
maintenant exact puis
c'est un bon coup sur la rigueur
journalistique aussi très apprécié on a
quand même fort l'europe ce n'est pas le
cas cela un petit peu plus tard avec lui
bernard qui nous parlait aussi de sa de
sa méthode pour avoir fait sont pas de
casse le dire je trouve que la vallée
similarités dans leurs discours peas et
malheureusement des problèmes
actuellement avec les médias c'est le
manque de rigueur journalistique de
plusieurs chroniqueurs en maintenant des
médias meanstream puis c'est dommage le
tir même si un inversement et de noms
qui font du travail incroyable nord-sud
sont des filles est justement qui n'a
pas parlé puis évidemment l dumont qui
font du travail de bombes sauf que c'est
l'fun de voir sa perspective à lui parce
que lui il l'a vu évoluer le monde des
médias s'essayer pile dedans est un
acteur clé du monde des médias depuis
son depuis les 25 dernières années 25
gaza n'effectuent vu ça évolue et puis
le fait qu'ils me disent souvent maton
qui ne surprenait pas le
conspirationnisme nautique et 2 0 / prix
d'un mouvement même parce que c'est
arrivé avant puisse avoir est arrivé
encore pis c'est vraiment cool de voir
ses perspectives là sur ce domaine le
web puis dire le parler beaucoup
justement de l'étau des médias l'état
des journaux maintenant trépied que
justement le fait qu'ils aient mettons
certains chroniqueurs de certains médias
peuvent être réunies meriem et oncle et
sa cause les amplis d'intérêt les écoles
dahmane et les clics pour les clics
c'est comme jusqu'où tu veux amener
c'est sûr que la rigueur va prendre
c'est un fait que puis l'arrivée aussi
des médias sociaux de 2010 aux
alternatives tout ce
saad bomb a beaucoup moins bon si une
fait que moins grosse réflexion sur les
médias
mais avec un gamer personnes pour en
parler honnêtement
on va les écouter un extrait sur le twin
cup extraits ce qui démarque les médias
j'apprends ce que de marquer mais dieu
crédible aujourd'hui justement c'est
leur crédibilité pseudo rigueur celle
exactitude des informations qu on y
retrouve qui justement que l'on commence
à se rendre compte à qui n'ont et qui ça
ça peut être dangereux justement joblo
qui écrit n'importe quoi surmonter
n'importe quoi sans évoquer le sujet pis
les médias traditionnels lyon la plupart
se soucie l'ubs c'est de voir le
d'exactitude cirque et maintenant il est
plus pertinent que jamais ce qui vient
avec pour beaucoup de gens
avec une certaine dose de frustration je
te donnais les
quins à l'été 2020 sa fille en a l'air
fait cesser ces
dénonciations sur instagram à propos de
marc pillas mort et les médias reçoivent
ce que sur soi ce jeudi premièrement je
peux pas juste prendre soin puis médecin
à la une du journal de montréal de la
presse du devoir
comme média tu peux pas faire ça une
obligation de vérification de
l'obligation d'essayer de parler à
toutes les parties impliquées comme
safia comme maripier morin mais moi je
me souviens que le lendemain sa fille
anna l'un d'eux peut-être pas la main
staut et même le jour même sa fille ne
rêve exprimé sa frustration du fait que
les médias traditionnels n'est pas en
avait pas de donner écho à ces
révélations
on peut pas faire ça
notre job notre force c'est de vérifier
de confirmer ou infirmer les bruits de
publier des affaires dont on a
vérifié la véracité ce qui ne veut pas
dire qu'on se trompe pas mais je me
souviens que autour de sa finale et y
avait beaucoup de gens qui disent eh ben
oui les médias ils font pas leur job non
pas des poursuites
coutts est patente pas des poursuites
que de vouloir
dire des choses qui sont vraies hélas sa
fillette dans mon souvenir il
se peut que je m'en charge dans quelques
détails mais sa fille anna l'un disait
quand il s'agit de parler de mon
habillement à l'adisq l'heure les médias
sont là oui évidemment on le voit un
chandail de gerry boulet on écrit qu'un
chalet de gerry boulet moi c'est pas mon
truc combien je n'écrirai pas là dessus
ça m'intéresse pas il ya des médias qui
ont beaucoup écrit là-dessus supporte un
chalet de la saint maron le voit
facilement vérifiable quant à l'aig
quelque chose comme ça
comme média je comprends que pour les
personnes qui sont pas versés dans
comment fonctionne le journaliste ça
peut être frustrant dans une époque où
tout était médias moi ça se fait que la
presse en parle pas
si on veut vérifier parce que dans cinq
ans c'est pas la page instagram dont on
va se répliquent les surtout dans
l'historie de 24 heures exactes sur ça
va être je posais oublié mais dans le
cas de sa fille a tellement fait un boom
soit pas oublié mais dans cinq ans c'est
dans la presse qu'on va aller voir ce
qui s'est dit dans la presse qu'on qu'on
va vérifier à comment ça a été dit à
quel moment donc un devoir de vérifier
puis plus que jamais quand le monde et
dans l'immédiateté com/media faut
toujours leur applique notre job c'est
de publier des trucs qui sont vrais et
ça c'est plus important qu'avec le
premier public oui c'est pour ça que
justement c'est
un travail comme l'a fait le devoir je
te mangerais pour rester dans la même
dans même période puis dans le même
mouvement le méthyle de voir qu'il y
avait peut-être aussi surgir la croix
neutre il y avait tout un travail
journalistique avait été fait qu'elle
rencontre et je pense neuf victimes ça
ça tombe qui je suis au csii et 11 sans
équivoque ne voudriez pas de doute à
guyot delà du travail qui est élève
versus un témoignage anonyme qui sort
sur instagram puis savait pas dire qui
est pas vrai mais il ya quand même entre
les deux il ya quelque chose qui est que
plus oui vous
savez ces listes en bas sont différents
puis ce qui veut pas dire que les gens
qui publient du contenu sur instagram au
pot leur utilité il y avait des enquêtes
journalistiques qui partent de ce qui
part dans les médias sociaux donc moi je
méprise pas ça du tout jusque le
standard est différent pissos ya
peut-être un travail de pédagogie de
notre part
podcast avec patrick lagacé ouais c'est
vrai grand nom
moi je l'appelle pas même nom qu'on leur
suffit pas de casse pattes patla
j'allais trouver un
essai de choisir ce qu'on sait de quoi
on choisit ses troupes il ya eu bout des
baux pas de 4,52 pas de cash ces regards
des peaux de castor choisir juste trop
par semaine
mais celui que j'ai choisi
il vient juste de sortir le tout
récemment est tout chaud sorti du four
tout chaud sorti du four avec louise
sigouin femme extraordinaire comment ne
pas de riz louise c'est encore paul oui
c'était prenant un petit copain avec qui
je parle de louise qui sait si qui fait
au louis est tellement hot est tellement
bien veillant notamment genre quand
t'écoutes mettons l'émission le 6 on
s'aimait sabre est tellement qui est qui
et bones qui a vu le tri le meilleur
pour etam à qt les puis
on nous a parlé des cinq dualité puis
moi t'aimer tonte et en écoutant
l'émission je suis convaincu c'est
intéressant duel team je comprenais pas
trop c'est quoi puis j'ai lu son livre
on en savoir plus jeu fait remaquer
intéressant c'est les 5 volts et parce
qu'elle utilise et
puis évidemment sur la falaise de
reconnaître comme acquis à sa mort sa
mort - sosa samba blanc ça ressemble à
mon amie assise puis on dirait ça
ça développe sur la sphère le
l'empathie à développer ok on est des
comportements différents métiers parce
qu'on est juste très différemment qu'il
faut qu'il faut que je comprenne que
l'autre fonctionne de moins moi je
fonctionne même si je comprends comment
je fonctionne je comprends comment
l'autre fonctionne facile de comprendre
les comportements facile de faire genre
depuis d'essayer de se retrouver dans le
milieu mais c'est facile de
de pauw faire jean voyons beaucoup de
façonnement pour coter été c'est comme
on est toutes constituées différemment
le tout différent en tout sur différents
spect d'égalité puis
à ce film et on dirait un exemple dans
l'évier plaint de
la situation qu'ils ont décrite comme
moi ça c'est telle personne ça c'était
moi dans le temps avec qui ça permet
justement de dégrad devenir un petit peu
plus mature monsieur peu plus
haut un petit peu plus de recul comment
de compréhension dans toutes les
situations de la vie non le fond non
encore plus d'amitié fait que sir
m'intéresse
ouais c'est sûr mais moi je pense même
cette année là on afghan fait une coupe
de podcasts sur les relations puis en
nettement je pense vraiment ce hack
accumulés à jour des conversations hors
micro mais souvent on arrivait dans un
dans un podcast ou ce qu'il y avait
quelque chose qui pas mais brand alley
mais qui venait me rejoindre vraiment
beaucoup un confrère maintenant puis
avec le package ou se coince est un
exemple lors de ce moment ce genre de
moments heureux qu est-ce que je ramène
ce chez nous puis la sasp inc le mettons
rien je parle vraiment souvent de sport
pur mais j'ai continué parce que je
trouve c'est la chose la plus importante
au monde mais là je vois courir me
trompe usa spin bloc au plomb direct du
problème solving puis j'applique mettons
ce à moi puis je déconstruis des
affaires puis j'essaie de
cash pour le micro de bord les
déconstruire personnes essayent de le
remettre dans l'ordre la bonne façon
c'est pour essayer de construire des
mécanismes numériser des patterns qui
est un peu un peu ce que louis sigouin
visiteurs puis 2 par ces conversations
là j'ai vraiment l'impression que
j'ai vraiment beaucoup amélioré ma
vision des relations puis ma tolérance
par rapport à certaines affaires comme
tu viens de dire le tigiste l'empathie
envers les autres mais aussi
la réelle compréhension de toi parce que
si tu comprends vraiment puis tu sais où
mettre des limites et frontières puis tu
sais aussi ou faut que tu mets ton
effort pour améliorer telle ou telle
affaire c'est pas mal facile de le
verbaliser rives de le dire dans une
relation et puis de table est vraiment
cédé un dialogue sain t il l'année a
commencé avec
duluc ki-moon parlé de cas une question
sur sur le podcast aussi tout ça mis
ensemble fait quelqu'un mac et je me
suis beaucoup amusé encore beaucoup de
chemin à faire
mais au moins ça a comme était un genre
de déclic au courant de l'annex culmine
avec
vous serez pop et une analyse plus clair
de ma personne selon mes cinq des
nullités ce qu'on a fait pendant
sparkasse l'appui on le fait pour nous
deux dans le fond on peut aller mettre
cet extrait là parce que c'est assez
parlant de commencer assez frappant le
fait que fait que support podcast avec
le sigle nikki mais cet extrait extrait
où j'ai de la misère à la plupart c'est
pas clair pour moi mettons des quel beau
spectacle mais trouve
des pandas coût dépendra maintenant je
taille de rapidement vous entendu tous
ces clubs pour tous moi pour moi vis à
vis moi c'est extrêmement rare que toi
c'est facile tout cas non mais c'est
vrai que toi c'est comme tu dis des
spéciaux et peut-être que toi ça ça
varie selon les salariés seront vers la
savane à sion je sais pas peut-être que
si je suis moyenne en quote part
qui est plus préoccupé par tes besoins
les besoins des autres je dirai à mes
besoins ok dépendants est ce que tu es
en vie tout est un là
je dirais vite parce que les chauffards
le plus de fois possible et vtt motifs
rationnels c'est un homme de beaucoup de
mots où tu t'es moche mais je ne dirais
pas vite aussi clairement qu sur le
soumettons ces parents mettons qu'on
compare d'une place pitt encore une
brosse à dents dans bouche avec genre
est en train de finir de 3 à faire parce
que l'estac où j'essaye définir du trot
à faire ce que je fais ce
choix je vais vraiment justes ou en
retard mais à cause que ouais faut que
je fasse le plus de choses étaient
quatre ans la
[Rires]
question c'est celle de
titi rationnelle ou les matières bain
certaines personnes dire est maintenant
ma blonde direct chez motif puis du
monde et que je travaille qui dirait que
je suis rationnelle impressionné avec
ton émotif qui fait 50 ans en même temps
il se voit c'est dans pitch est qu un
peu nouvelle puisque dans notre affaire
puisse à tout ça vient de lever tôt au
ralenti avec des temps là parce que tu
te marche au feeling du web pâte aménagé
dans bas des dossiers ouverts qu'en fait
c'est celui c'est ce qui me confirme
gâter leurs enfants parce que tu es
quand même enfin aux pics atteints typé
bonhomme a obligé un mot et son running
a pris 85 et c'est messi parce que je
marche au feeling tactile
émotif l'un et quoi d'autres actifs rêve
et quand même je travaille peut-être
qu'ils différents noms mais même même
d'été quand même rationnelle mais je
pense qu'ils étaient ton rationnel qui
parle pas trop le de ses émotions
m'étonne c'est la dualité rationnelle et
motifs l'aï vraiment rationnelles sont
ils pas l affaire de com était super
cartésien sur mettons les études ces
choses-là la science petit truc là sauf
que sauf que tu dis parle pas des
émotions vraies non plus qui sont
relatés émotions pour toi
tu clair comment tu ressembles à ton
sont incapables de nommer
ouais mais c'est assez
ça c'est également ce que
sera qu'une journée je vais devrait
entraîner le non respect nécessairement
dans l'expression l'espace parce que
probablement lui doit au niveau du
travail peut-être que nous va mourir
et qui sait peut-être cet acte des
champs d'intérêt qui sont très cartésien
et intellectuel mais en fait en relation
quantité qu ce crime est ce que tu t'es
un homme de peu de mots août et un autre
qui s'expriment librement et facilement
c'est là que ça va le déterminer sur un
axe sommes librement et pas seulement ok
c'est plus rationnel enfants voulaient
rationnelle sont très sensibles c'est
pas grâce younès pas des pierres peut
déjà pas de carte c'est juste que quand
il s'exprime c'est des mots qui sortent
au lieu que ce soit une émotion
ta classe atteints figurait plus sur le
rationnel pas qu'un dépassement
rationnelle 1 c'est quoi qui reste actif
rêveur dit en arrivant un amoureux un
laveur puis qu'est-ce qui a fusionné
seul tu as même se passer du temps qu'on
connaît au thème plus faire toutes tes
enfants qui rentrent à la maison peut
être content de retrouver table on
juge caricature rapidement la meute on
le met
se sait pas que la
cachette avec ma blonde je suis très
présent oui mais on peut être des
lambeaux de 5 ans semble hébétée tout
est bien puisque ce trialisant ta job on
voit tes amis toi ta famille tu as des
activités étaient bien ne faire ces
enfants là aussi mais c'est
principalement le premier point le job
les amis de paris c'est moins présent
peu mais c'est surtout ce fait car tu es
là tu es l'homme et aime se réaliser un
jour d'un mal de tête parfait enfin que
probablement plus insultant mais quand
tu es le tellure cheveux et on est de
retour et de retour c'était podcast avec
louis sigouin puis je repense à ce que
tu disais vous avant le tipi
le chemin team et on mois soit madame à
la sionge est de loin la meilleure
communication avant 9 heures dans ma vie
maintenant avec un couple me donne
puis c'est sûr que toutes les
discussions qui ont eu ou pas de caste
on fait en sorte qu'aujourd'hui je suis
comme meilleur que j'ai été j'ai caché
des enfants avec comme toi c'est comme
des fois il ya des facs sont dit si
comme acquis
ça sentait bon sens la presse c'est
comme
moi
le nouveau délai nous trois moments
préférés de l'année
nicole qui est là avec nous nicole qui
est plus dans le calme quand on a changé
sa position peu près six fois un accueil
a passé deux ans en 2021 et qu'elle ya
passé deux mois accroupis en petit
bonhomme dans le coin la pièce parce
qu'on n'avait pas encore sorti la
technique dans l'unique à lille c'est un
vrai on a déménagé de laquelle vous avez
déménagé local
dgd mal de dos à n'en plus finir
maintenant de val-d'or coup c'est à
cause de la chaîne avec laquelle on
s'attache à bureaux
commence à être tanné aussi de bord
uniquement d'un flag
dans le panneau dans le cadre
cette année là dessous
non mais moi ma pauvre et il y en a eu
plein à des podcasts mais
le podcast avec jean martin fortier m'a
vraiment rester en tête dray qui est
arrivé dans un moment aussi où ou qu'on
parlait beaucoup de
d'acheter local puis on en a parlé
on en a parlé beaucoup évidemment je
demande qu'ils l'appuient nous expliquez
nous a vraiment bien fait comprendre
pourquoi c'est important fait je trouve
de de consommer local qui puis au delà
de ceux aussi ce que j'ai trouvé nice
c'est qu'il parlait de 2 comment il
faisait pour optimiser sa ferme à lui
comme tel type celui d'il ya 1 hector
mais la réalité c'est quelqu'un
c'est des gros producteurs debout film
et on ne sait pas combien d'hectares
mais comme ses seins fini mon plus gros
qu est-ce que lui qui que ce que lui
mais par contre lui il ya développé ses
propres techniques d'optimisation pour
arriver ben pas concurrencer en termes
de la maximisation l'espoir à maximiser
vraiment son espace à lui puis c'était
quand même c'était comme pour moi
c'était un univers qui était loin
vraiment de ce que je connais mais
c'était super intéressant en fait puis
il ya vraiment bien réussi et accuser
tout ce moment ça a vraiment un podcast
fort la dernière année comme tout pour
tout pas de casque aux fonds distincts
pas de casque est resté qui m'a fait
aussi réfléchir aussi sûr et c'est tout
les gaspillage alimentaire en chine on
en a parlé beaucoup à y est pillé puis
non moi ça m'a fait réfléchir piaf en
fait changer les habitudes tgv nord -
mettront le après après qu'il soit venu
j'ai commencé à faire quelque chose j'ai
commencé à aller à boulangerie sur
wellington pour gagner mon pain puisse
exercer ses rien leucémie multi on
s'entend le dépeignaient les eaux lui le
panier à l'épicerie de payet mais je
dois pas et mène déjà 2 fois par semaine
à boulangerie symbolique sur deux jours
mais six autres bonjour monsieur j'en
profite pour me prendre un croissant et
on le dit aux gens où l évoquions à ce
moment là que j'amène ce chez nous
puisque c'est mon pain mettons puis gg
je me suis pas inscrit malheureusement
encore à un panier de bouffe sauf que ce
que j'ai fait j'ai d'application parce
que j'ai une collab avec cette
application les qui s'appelle to good to
go puis ces genres il donne des
tu vas voir maintenant à chaque jour
plus vendre des paniers de non vendus
dans les commerces locaux au bâton le
fait que le d'ubs à acheter un panier
qui vaut j'en revends et pias à genre
trois pièces 99 parce qu'ils m'ont jeté
les enfants j'ai commencé à faire ce
plus souvent puis dancoisne werden ne
sait vraiment mais c'est toutes les
valeurs qui en avait aussi de proximité
de communautés si c'est vraiment y
mettons le retour à parler avec tantôt
of camelot et de
deux mouvements de retour au village
aussi dire un taux de ce crédit d'aidé
des micro communautés c'est justement
jeu par les deux camps s'étaient jamais
enregistré dans un village c'est à
saint-adrien typique et il ya vraiment
une espèce de d'europe d'artistes de
créateurs qui sont le pis c'est tout
tout est full
traditionnel parce que ça village mais
moderne en même temps l'épicerie en vrac
24 heures pour rentrer à deux heures du
matin panis que tu veux le faisait payer
sa libre service s'en sortir dans ces
drames à qom puis c'est vraiment un gang
de monde le ti qui font de leur faire
incroyable pu choquer les valeurs de
même au québec y en a plein de plus en
plus ou moins avec lui tu vas chercher
justement dit on c'est comme une espèce
de casement d'autosuffisance le nom de
derrek lee d'agriculteurs bis bis de ce
contact le avec
avec sa bouffe aussi le tri avec aimé
ton d'aller chercher le tout par le
dessus branger métier d'aller d'aller au
marché jean-talon d'allaiter fidèles de
d'envoi le feeling qui était
d'adtoma talent été cueilli par steagall
kita donne puisqu'elle a été comme moi
entretenu fait pousser avec amour avec
ketty avec ses pieds
ne touchent pas dans cette affaire mais
c'est ce qui fait dire devant notamment
être déconnecté qui a été on oublie
casement qui est monté au travail en
ligue 2 la viande qu'on oublie que c'est
quelque chose qui sonne un maxi de
retrouver cette proximité là avec la
bouffe mais c'est pas quelque chose qui
fait tout ce que j'ai de plus qu'avant
un peu parce que je cuisine vraiment
plus mais
mais ça c'est comme le fun d'être
vraiment cuisiner les choses à sa saison
c'est d'avoir un espace de contacts avec
des liens avec les territoires la terre
les écrits nantes je veux ce book tous
les ballons vraiment nichols métro
l'extrait qui plaît pour ce yeah yeah
extraits extraits pour moi j'ai acheté à
felsberg un clapier donc c'était un
ancien bâtiment où il y avait des latins
c'était cat hector j'ai payé cent mille
fait que ce n'est même pas une ferme la
base neutre à acheter sur le terrain
tout mon modèle à moi est né de ma
contraintes d'espacé que si j'avais cat
hector j'ai trop en beau que je que je
voulais pas coupé c'est une érablière
puis fait que j'avais un hector puis au
milieu de ça il y avait un clapier qu'il
faisait sens par 40 que j'ai divisé en
deux j'ai construit ma maison dans une
partie s'était d'ailleurs c'était comme
un grosse bâtisse comme ici le geffray
mais des planches et des plafonds
souhaite une maison mais ma contraintes
de terrain c'est que j'avais un hector
que moi j'ai voulu la rentabiliser la
maximiser développer des techniques pour
toujours faire plus de légumes plus de
légumes sur un hectare c'est ça qui a
créé mon modèle comment comment est né
me tape très fort c'est un peu
faire des choix qui t'ont amené vers la
méthode que tout c'est pour ça que j'ai
pas tracteur parce que le tracteur est
finalement il promet de la place le cari
tourner quand il tourne au bout du rêve
peut pas avoir des carottes la
secte est moins tucak m car il était
temps légumes série tate je travaille
des outils manuels
si j'avais voyagé à cuba j'avais vu des
trucs la boj avait en france j'avais vu
des trucs là bas en californie fait que
j'ai tout ramené c'est ici puis on a mis
tout en place un système qui est
vraiment super performant mais xu outils
manuels qui coûte pas cher
fake pour répondre à la question tantôt
c'est les jeunes qui sortent de mig ils
sont pas besoin d'être propriétaires ils
peuvent louer un temps laissé partir une
business se montrent et dessert il doit
après 2,3 à lyon un petit mise de fonds
ils ont un business qui cela ils peuvent
à lalbenque des écoutes moi je vais
acheter une terre je vais acheter une
maison est foutu le fasse par étapes
avec mais le modèle que moi je moi je
fais permettre mais toi un conteneur sur
un de mes oncles ou un demi-hectare puis
t'es grave par l'argent
sur stoner qui fait comme il légumes
différente du film et en combien de
récolte dans une saison tu peux faire
moi je vais faire deux à trois légumes
par on a tout dit viser lecteurs en
planches comme on a dit bloc des
planches trop faire des successions donc
tu dises mettons que ça que lui en ce
moment je ramasse et des radis que j'ai
semé
japon au début mars
je vais aller ramasser après ce jeu
c'est le même jour je vois transplanter
des laitues et l'ailette suivons 1,40 jo
puis après si jamais des haricots et que
je vais avoir dans une même planche
trois légumes puis mais espacement de
culture mes haricots sont vraiment serré
parce que avec un tracteur quand tu
vieillis pour désherber tu as besoin de
laisser ben de la place entre chaque
rame pour que l'outil pas où ce mot si
votre audi avec fait croit comprendre
ainsi ses effectifs etc tout est
dimensionnée pour que ton tracteur
circulent fake terrain sont loin tandis
que moi mettons au luc avoir trop orange
carotte comme sage et j'en ai cinq ici
parce que j'ai pas besoin d'aller cercle
avec un tracteur fait non seulement je
fais 2 3 les trois légumes différents
par planche mais migrants sont cinq fois
plus serrés fait que je suis un acteur
mais dans le fond je produis comme si
j'étais sur 10 puis il ya bien des
bennes et des
bénéfices des bénéfices à face au même
titre des coûts de production moins des
plus efficaces dans tes gestes d'anti
mouvement fait que faisons nous voilà de
retour nous voici des photos avant de
clore l'année de clôture et
sébastien duret ce best-of on va faire
un petit des mentions une coupe de
mention honorable parce qu'il est
tellement podcast on pourrait nous
mettre à l'infini extrait pour chacun
des périodes mais y en a certains qui ne
marque plus voter commandés au regard de
la liste oui ça c'était vraiment quelque
chose moi j'avais andrée marquis oui on
a marqué puis ça je pense que c'est un
truc qui a été le plus partagé parlement
de londres et que ça vraiment comme en
tchéquie le plus écouté aussi les
écouter c'est comme le prévoir casque
affaisé un piti à est vraiment
extraordinaire maé fait tache en gros
les boubli iphone a été
pillé à la une histoire tiges d
entrepreneuriat de même de succès des
story from de bordeaux s'est inspiré en
pareil cas que d'expliquer que si ça a
commencé en est à 15 mille pièces dans
le rouge
cette première semaine c'est comme
c'était le setter of le togo puis en y
croyant plus en travaillant fort bien en
temps des brouilleurs c'est comme devenu
ce que c'est devenu c'est andrée anne
moi je les revues coupe deux fois après
dans d'autres contextes gang et se met à
parler de business tout le monde ferme
sa gueule tu fermes d'ailleurs sur
écoute parce que tu bois ces mots le
genre c'est comme est vraiment vraiment
charpy monfils lui demande qui
sait comme elle habite rillieux
maintenant et un monde qui est comme
c'est comme évident fiable et on
commente alors
quand les talents pour la musique en
écho notamment pour la peinture pied qui
ont été remboursés
sur son moto à
rien c'est dans doute gaz au bois mais
c'était ça marche si tu les intuitions
qu'elle allait parce que joblo qui se
dit dans le haut de gamme dans le dos de
gaz au bois de khimki double hypothèque
sa maison pour lancer sa compagnie de
lush et packs web marche pas partout
n'est pas ce qui est allé dans le goût
dans le doute et quitte à la gorge au
bout tu
vas y avait lui roger godbout cela c'est
vraiment intéressant cardozo sûrement ça
m'a aidé beaucoup attendent en baisse
comme ce qui s'appelle du monde moi même
je suis docteur de dos puis y'a pas que
je comprends pas ouais c'était dans la
lignée est justement plus scientifiques
experts scientifiques sur des domaines
si on l'avait fait l'an passé
la maison qui est avec le stress ou non
à la mémoire l'année ne fait plusieurs
mais
surtout de bois s'était tu es pas sa
personnalité ou appuyé par le sujet
c'était
vraiment puis je veux danser sur tout le
monde dorme une bonne partie civile et
qui m'aident à jouer en profiter comme
simon
vincent vallières alias est le fun
c'est sûr ça va être sympa de casser
comme j'ai l'impression de parler ou
moins difficilement exact c'est comme si
on sort semblait un peu d'où on venait
comme de genre de famille déjà deux
des parcours de vie mais juste comme lui
comme et plus vous en avance
c'est qu'un conte par l'iccat il parlait
de
steam et ont débuté début trentaine ses
calmes et on va s'aimer encore ressenti
comme une certaines maisons commencent à
former beaucoup de diéthyle de il a 21
ans comme les deux
comme beaucoup de choses que
personnellement on a dit que j'avais
vécu c'est vraiment ouais c'est un bon
pas de casse vraiment moi parce
qu'actuellement puis temanava
c'était d'aller podcast maintenant
on a moins fait un peu ternes et de
départ 15 vraiment genre de
de
coryton la fin juste comme yahoo en même
temps on ne dit pas la fario prennent le
thé mettons les discussions ni femme ce
dessert est la leur et leur
vision de tissus l'opinion là-dessus
sincèrement bon ouais sont vraiment
drôles
qui misait qui s'est si vous voulez en
fait long feu un best-of 2021 mais si
vous voulez qu a soufflé un commentaire
sur les podiums ce qu'on a fait c'est
pas mal ça qu'on l'a fait quand même été
levée jeudi par les députés qu'est ce
qu'on a fait depuis rajoutez à rajouter
son interprétation de
forêt mais ça compte que ce qu'on aille
plus loin
c'est comme arrivé en partant plomb
avait quelque chose le fait qu'on
retiendra c'est ouais c'est ça c'est
comme à la vie comme écouter patrick a
accumulé quelque chose qu'elle a envie
10 pts alex à sa table et ce soit vis à
vis à qui ce qui s'abritait kamenar
entre ce que fait que web avec avec kim
c'est vraiment le fun ja c'est comme
s'il
voulait percer les
personnages carapace
c'est comme alsace canaliser
mes
coups après ce que j'avais on ne parle
est entouré qu'au giro quelque chose
avec olivier tout le temps le fun avait
clairement
fait que moi ça fait le tour doit être
plus beaux parcs à thème en écoute
fister un autre belles années du
sans-fil podcast semaine c'est une
troisième année
un petit peu plus
tout le temps incroyable on échangera
crise on est vraiment privilégié il faut
se rappeler c'est vraiment le fun de
faire toutes ces rencontres là que ces
gens incroyables d'avoir la tribune qui
nous permet de les inviter de deux
pouvoir rendre ce genre de discussion
l'axé c'est bojan puis et merci surtout
à vous que nous écouter parce que sans
vous autres la flore tu parles pour
avoir la caméra sur toi et merci à toi
de nous écouter à la maison
parce que ça à vous il n'y aurait pas de
sans fil puis latine merci beaucoup
bonne année puis abuja d'hommes noirs et
fine
des mines de houille et
du contenu excellent tu as tout un
podcast convient
oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur une pétillante de pétion vous
abonner pour trop de leur part mais
aussi trop de la mouette trois pièces
par morlaàs par mois ils avaient les
pattes carte en avance acquise avec les
premiers de votre groupe d'amis avoir
quitté les podcasts qu'ils allaient
avoir pouvoir avoir une avance quand
vous allez tirer la dynamique entre les
amis sultan avons une avance sur les
jobs en avance ou entre deux toits mais
avec pétillante une avance sur
l'humanité complète en plus en plus
parce que leur chèque le podcast unis
voulaient me tendant jazz ou davantage
on fait des encore moins de filtres à
préchac podcast avec là on vient de
finir de tourner le podcast on vend
jaser on va être pile et nicole non
nicole il pleut maintenant comme un fils
travaille à plat ce détail est là mais
on jase on parle de conversion qu'on
m'aide à voir mais ce si vous voulez
avoir accès
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous s'est excusé
sur têtu il faut s'abonner abonnez vous